cédric crampons bonjour bonjour madame
vous êtes candidat aux élections
législatives où vous présenter dans la
circonscription de fort de france sur la
liste du rassemblement national alors
pourquoi avez vous tenu à participer à
être candidat sur ce scrutin et bien
tout d'abord parce que j'ai la tristesse
de constater que les choses n'évoluent
pas ça fait quelques années déjà que
j'observe la vie politique martiniquaise
est elle aussi nationale mais ici en
particulier
il n'y a pas vraiment de changement c
est stagnant les mêmes personnes soto
remplace se cooptent mais c'est pas
satisfaisant alors qu'elle sera quels
seront vos deux ou trois projets
prioritaires si vous deviez être élu à
l'assemblée nationale concernant le
territoire globalement de la martinique
est bien pour moi en fait la vraie
priorité
c'est l'emploi il faut créer de l'emploi
il faut créer de l'activité et on a un
gros déficit d'activité industrielle
d'activité donc pour créer de l'emploi
et paradoxalement je pense que c'est
dans les le recyclage et les choses
affiliés qu' on peut enfin trouvé la
solution pourquoi parce qu'à chaque fois
on fait des projets mirobolants qui
demandent des des centaines de millions
d'euros à droite à gauche à l'europe à
la france on a toujours dans une
position attentiste et l'idée c'est
vraiment de se débrouiller par nous
mêmes avec des ressources qui sont déjà
là avec des investissements a minima en
mettant des gens au travail et donc sur
les met au travail forcément on crée de
l'emploi et avec des ressources qui sont
déjà là donc par exemple faire un projet
pour utiliser les sargasses plutôt que
de s'en plaindre constamment ariana y en
a eu en arabe faisant faisons quelque
chose avec nos voisins de la caraïbe les
mexicains ont pour inventer un procédé
pour transformer des sargasses en
parpaings nous on importe des parpaings
utilisant les sargasses comme ça on
apporte plus on fabrique les nôtres
c'est mieux et on utilise quelque chose
qui nous embarrasser nous dérange de la
même façon toute personne qui a
se déplace en martinique dès qu'ils
quittent la ruda voies principales et
rentre dans une route secondaire trouve
des carcasses de voitures partout tous
les cadavres qui encombrent tous les
chemins utilisons cette ressource c'est
de la ferraille c'est du verre du
plastique du caoutchouc plein de choses
on prend ça on désosse ça on le démonte
et on récupère toutes les matières qui
le composent pour justement en refaire
des matières premières en a pas ou le
recyclage c'est une solution pour la
marque on importe des tôles fonds dont
les voitures l'arrivée à celle qui nous
encore qui nous embarrasse on les fait
fondre on a de la tôle pourquoi faire
venir de la tôle de france d'espagne et
d'ailleurs on en a chez nous et en plus
ça supprime les problématiques aussi
avec les histoires de dengue et tout ça
dont on ne parle plus depuis l'avènement
du coc vide mais tout cva chu qui sont
partout là ce sont que des nids à
moustiques et là du coup autant on va en
faire vous fait des remarques dans un
cimetière pour ne pas mettre un pot de
fleurs mais à d énormes pots de fleurs à
4 ou dans toute la martinique c'est ma
priorité c'est de gérer ce problème
concernant la circonscription dans
laquelle vous vous présentez fort de
france quel serait d'après vous les
projets aux gens sur lesquels il
faudrait plancher si vous êtes élu à
l'assemblée nationale vient fort france
et un gros pôle de par le fait mine de
rien d'habitation de logement tout est
concentré il ya un vrai problème de
logement il ya aussi un problème
malheureusement de criminalité et donc
il faut à la fois donner des solutions
c'est à dire on revient à l'histoire de
l'emploi mais aussi essayer de réguler
la situation crée une structure peut
être plus adapté augmenter le
dimensionnement du logement certainement
pour créer de la grande banlieue c'est à
dire faire les gens aller un peu plus
loin que tout le monde à glu tini hau
d'autres foires de france ce qui crée en
plus comme partout ailleurs dès que tout
le monde se colle au même endroit les
prix augmentent et c'est donc ça devient
inabordable il faut mieux aller habiter
un peu plus loin donc créer des choses
en partenariat avec les communes
limitrophes pour que justement on puisse
d engranger un peu mais en même temps il
faut réguler en particulier dès qu'il
fait nuit etc il faut améliorer la
sécurité publique illégale
il ya un gros travail à faire
qu'avez-vous doute qu avez-vous d'autres
à dire et à rajouter ou aux électeurs eh
bien ma candidature elle est là pour
revendiquer le changement
malheureusement la majorité des gens qui
aujourd'hui
représentent des partis qui sont déjà
connus ultra connue l'autre à présent
les ppm et autres malheureusement force
est de constater que sur la durée 10 ans
15 ans 20 ans qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
leur
efficacité par rapport à la durée de
leur exercice
là y'a pas grand chose à dire
malheureusement c'est un triste constat
donc voté pour le changement voté pour
quelque chose de nouveau
de toute façon
revoter pour les mêmes qui ne font rien
ou voter pour quelqu'un qui est a envie
et qui veut faire quelque chose a priori
c'est mieux
cédric camperont merci je voudrais ici